the last time we saw each other we were
talking on a couch
and i think your feet up that one
that was a memorable moment that was fun
but i mean i'm excited to talk to you
now but i'm also a little bit sad or a
lot of a bit sad actually the fifth and
final season of the show ryan are you
okay with this
yeah you know it's it's it's it's nice
that we have the opportunity to you know
end the story and you know the writers
have an opportunity to bring it to a
close and um you don't always get that
opportunity and so that's nice and i
think
you know i feel really proud of the show
that we've done and the stories we've
been able to tell and and you know i
think there's really something beautiful
about examining these big macro issues
through the micro through the individual
level and
how when you help one person you can
really
create a ripple effect to make a change
i think a lot of the messaging on the
show is is really good stuff that i at
least i've taken to heart and
and yeah i'm excited for what's next and
um
and we'll see
you know is it hard to say goodbye to a
character
yeah for sure it is but you know the
thing about tv is like
you know i've been with this character
for this is the fifth season now so
you're you you know it's easy to
you you know like when you do a film
it's like you shoot for a couple weeks
by the last week you're like i think
i've got the character now and then you
finish
you know but with the series you have
all these years to explore
who this guy is in different
circumstances and different
relationships and so yeah i feel like
i've had some good time with um
with dr max goodwin and uh
yeah it's been cool that you know people
come up on the street and say
i was watching in the hospital with my
you know grandmother or or someone you
know i i had a woman on the street
driving
um stop traffic in new york which is uh
not not always wise
um
she was on her way to get a
chemo treatment and she was talking
about you know
this character having cancer which eric
who the characters based on had and and
beat it and
um
and how the you know she appreciated
watching that journey and i those those
those moments are uh
you know
yeah and really make a character like
max goodwin who embodies helping people
and generosity of spirit um worth worth
playing yeah for sure goodbyes are never
easy and we had to say goodbye to frema
for season five she's so powerful on
screen i loved watching the two of you
together
just super iconic was it hard to say
goodbye there
i know the two of your friends off
camera too though
of course yes we are uh but then i just
i just really couldn't take working with
her anymore and i just said get her out
so i called i i we pulled the plug uh it
was really dramatic dance she actually
hit me
on set and i had a scar here
uh that that didn't happen um i uh yes i
love love playing those scenes with
frima she's so wonderful and
you know we found something uh special
yeah really fun to play with really
unique and um i will really miss playing
those scenes and i hope that we get the
opportunity to do something like that
again in the future
did you have a favorite scene or an
episode that you shared together
[Music]
uh there was a there was a bunch of
moments that were so fun to play
with frima but i'm trying to think of a
favorite um
i mean you'll see in the in the in
episode
one of the new season
you know without giving anything away
you see a few moments from the past and
so i had to look at like some old clips
and stuff and it was very nostalgic
all the way back to like episode one
season one walking through the hallway
meeting her um
and then um and like their first hug and
then their first kiss remember that i
remember all of those so that must be
epic for you because it gives you the
goosebumps it was good yeah totally it
was fun it really was and it was
interesting because his i think their
first
hug that was in
i think that was season
one and a season one um
i think he was still married at the time
so it was an interesting uh
interesting journey to to
to play and then he was yeah it was a
lie yeah yeah
how does max being left at the altar
by her
at the end of season four affect him
this season like i know he can't say a
lot but what can you say
yeah he um because we want you happy we
want max happy he's already married to
someone else he meets a girl at a bar he
goes to vegas and he's married
he's not that guy yes it's great
her name is um uh charlie no um
yeah it's you know we we addressed it in
in the first episode and and um
devastating obviously and it's you know
for a show that's about healing
um that's certainly a part of this
journey for max for season five
um
is is healing and figuring this out and
understanding this and um
and then yeah and the end that you know
the end of this thing is sort of
not
totally written yet there's sort of
different ways so
we'll see i'm excited to see how it
comes to a close yeah so could max then
return as medical director of new
amsterdam this season
um oh you bet your bottom dollar yeah
there's no way i'm giving uh new
amsterdam to to uh to anybody else it's
uh
he loves this hospital too much
how is the real life cast going to
celebrate all of this the the final
episodes like are you going to be doing
any parties is there anything happening
is there a group chat what are you doing
and can we invite it
absolutely 100 not joking and um
also i generally just come to set uh
drunk
just celebrates
um and i kind of you know passed out
beers for everybody and we just drink
all day and we don't really shoot
anything anymore no it's it's really fun
um actually this season because
we uh you know there's like this weird
sort of
there's like there's sort of like an in
the moment appreciation of of the family
that we've lived with for these years
now you know the crew and the cast and
everybody and have definitely made some
like you know some friendships for life
and
and certainly some amazing creative
collaborations and
so yeah there's it's a really
good vibe this year because there's sort
of i don't know just an appreciation of
that and that it's not going to last
forever that in a few months we're going
to be done and
and so everybody's kind of loving on
each other an extra little bit and um
it's really fun but yeah i i hope
there's i mean i'm yes we're gonna we're
gonna throw a party
um
it would be fun i don't know where or
when i kind of suggested axe throwing
which is maybe a liability i i feel like
maybe i feel like maybe not that
just
but you could come to canada and we
could do that one time if you'd like but
maybe not for the cast and crew to
celebrate something i'll take you axe
throwing we'll lose a few toes no big
deal there's fake doctors there'll be
fake doctors there there's nothing in
the morning to fix it all
yeah
what do you have to say to all the
die-hard fans of this show because i
feel like we came in fast and furious
when we watched the show you immediately
became invested into the characters into
the story lines and you know it reminded
people of different moments in their own
lives going through different various
things and as you said talking about
really important issues
but there's some die-hard fans that can
be really sad to see this go
yeah man i i don't know what i would say
other than
it's been amazing to share these stories
with an audience over the years and to
build a um a sort of a damn fam you know
of of of folks who appreciate the show
and
and um
you know the most interesting stories to
me today are are true stories stories
that are based on real people in real
life and you know a lot of these
episodes are are based on
uh real life um or real people or real
events and
um and they're about things that affect
our lives um in in real ways and
so yeah
it go to and um
you know i get you know i guess if it
went forever i mean the fact that
something else is what makes it precious
and have value you know so i think that
i think
i think yeah it'll be
it'll be bittersweet um to say goodbye
but
the people i've met over the years who
are fans of the show who've said hello
on the street or elsewhere online or
something um
have been amazing uh people with stores
i mean we've met nurses and doctors who
watched the show um yeah at bellevue you
know that the hospital is based on we've
met patients we've met just
folks from different walks of life fans
and it's all those relationships have
always been very
um
inspiring really inspiring to hear from
people just about their own life and how
the show has maybe you know either
affected them or how there was a a story
that we got right or got wrong you know
which we've got which we've done too and
um
yeah it's been it's been really cool to
be a part of that for these years
nice i'm excited i know your fans are
excited that you are coming to toronto
you are coming to tiff this year for a
jazz man's blues by tyler perry
talk about this this isn't the first
time the two of you have worked together
talk about what this relationship means
to you
yeah sure um well first i'm really
excited to go to toronto uh i love that
city and i haven't been there in years
and i am very excited i went to the
festival one time before uh for another
film years ago and i had the best time
um
and
yeah tyler perry is an amazing
filmmaker amazing guy he's built a whole
empire you know in atlanta his own
studio and he's making so many things
and he's such a creative
force and a kind generous person
uh to boot um
yeah this is my second film with him and
he wrote this film
years ago um when he was much younger
before he had any sort of you know
success and and has been wanting to make
this
for a long time it has it has music in
it it's a period piece in the 40s it's a
really cool special story
so yeah i'm excited really excited to be
back in toronto
speaking of period pieces
i i text you and told you that i am
watching 90210 the reboot right now
so all right
well here's the thing i'm watching it
with my son and boy are there some
talking points
also
which is like i don't even remember i
mean you'd have to remind me it's so
many years ago
it's
it's amazing it's amazing and and
watching you now and kind of knowing a
little bit more about you and stuff like
that i get a kick out of watching it i
think it's really great it's super fun
to watch
that was one of my first jobs i think my
first series regular job i had just done
a show called dirt before that with
courtney cox which is a great series
that went down because of the writer's
strike i really wish that show had
continued um
um but um
all i remember on 90210 is that
i
in like my first episode or something
they started kind of a romance
flirtation between me and i think anna
lynn mccord
yes as a teacher-student naughty thing
and immediately we're like we're not
doing that
yeah like they're immediately like with
this character we have to go we do that
we can't do that and so them and then we
change courses um but that's all i
remember it's like
in an episode like flirting with a
student and being like oh are we doing
this and then the next episode would be
like we're not doing that it's like okay
no there were so many turns there's been
so many turns but i just i know you
think it i think it's epic i think it's
epic so just want you to know
it was cool working with with with jenny
and and um you know some of the
originals was the coolest thing ever uh
jenny was so sweet and um it it was a
blast i'm actually seeing gabe
um
sax who was a producer on that show and
just you know such a good guy sort of
mentor and friend and i haven't seen him
in years and he's in new york soon so um
i'm gonna tell him that you said hi and
then you can watch the show yeah
definitely do well when you're here you
have to stop here at ut canada come and
say hi i will i would love to yeah i'm
really excited i'm only there for two
days but i haven't been there so long
and i'm really genuinely super excited
to be
back amazing well thanks for taking the
time
of course good to see you